[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this is cs50 and this is the
start of week two and you'll recall that
over the past couple of weeks we've been
building up first initially from scratch
the graphical programming language that
we then just last week translated to the
equivalent program in C and of course
there is a lot more syntax now it's
entirely text but the ideas recall were
we're fundamentally the same the catch
is that computers don't understand this
they only understand what language yeah
zeros and ones are binary and so there's
a requisite step in order for us to get
from this code to binary and what was
that step for that programmer process
called yeah so compiling and of course
recall as you've now experimented with
this past week that's a compile program
you can use clang for C language and you
can just say clang and then the name of
the file that you want to compile and
that outputs by default it's a pretty
oddly named program just a dot out which
stands for assembler output more on that
in just a moment but recall too that you
can override that default behavior and
you can actually say output instead a
program called hello instead of just a
dot out but you can go one step further
and you can actually use make and make
itself is not a compiler it's a build
utility but in layman's terms what does
it do for us it compiles it and it
essentially figures out all of those
otherwise cryptic looking command-line
arguments like - Oh something and so
forth so that the program is built just
the way we want it without our having to
remember those seemingly magical
incantations and though that only works
for programs as simple as this in fact
some of you with the most recent problem
set might have encountered compilation
errors that we actually did not
encounter deliberately in class because
make was helping us out in fact as soon
as you enhance a program to actually
take user input using cs50 library by
including cs50 dot H some of you might
have realized that all of a sudden the
sandbox and more generally clang didn't
know what getstring was and frankly
clang might not even known what a string
was and that's because those two are
features of cs50 library that you have
to teach clang about but it's not enough
to teach clang what they look like as by
including
yes 50h turns out there's a missing step
that make helps us solve but that you
two can just solve manually if you want
and by that I mean this instead of
compiling a program we're just clang
hello dot see when you want to use cs50
s library you actually intend to add
this additional command-line arguments
specifically at the end can't go in the
beginning like - oh and - L stands for
link and this is a way of telling clang
by the way when compiling my program
please link in cs50 zeros and ones that
we the staff wrote some weeks ago and
installed in the sandbox for you so
you've got your zeros and ones and then
you've got our zeros and ones so to
speak and - L cs50 says to link them
together so if you were getting some
kind of undefined reference error to
getstring or you didn't you weren't able
to compile program that just used any of
the get functions from cs50 library odds
are this simple change - L cs50 would
have fixed but of course this is an
interesting stuff to remember let alone
remembering how to use - OH as well at
which point the command gets really
tedious to type so here comes make again
make automates all of this for us and in
fact if you henceforth start running
make and then pay closer attention to
the fairly long line of output that it
outputs you'll actually see mention of -
L cs50 you'll see mention of even - L M
which stands for math so if you're using
round for instance you might have
discovered that round two also doesn't
work out of the box unless you use make
itself or this more nuanced approach so
this is all to say that compiling is a
bit of a white lie like yes we've been
compiling and you've been going from
source code to machine code but it turns
out that there's been a number of other
steps happening for you that we're gonna
just slap some labels on today at the
end of the day we're just breaking the
abstraction so compiling is this
abstraction from source code to machine
code let's just kind of zoom in briefly
to appreciate what it is that's going on
in hopes that it makes the code we're
compiling a little more understandable
so step one of four when it comes to
actually compiling a program it's called
pre-processing so recall that this
program we just looked at had a couple
of includes at the top of the file these
are generally known as preprocessor
directives not a particularly
interesting term but they're demarcated
by the hash at the start of these lines
that's a
no to clang that these things should be
handled first pre-processed process
before everything else and in fact the
reason for this we did discuss last week
inside of cs50.h is what for instance
getstring specifically that the
declaration of getstring so there's some
lines of code the prototype if you
recall that one line of code that
teaches clang what the inputs to
getstring are and what the outputs are
the return type and the arguments so to
speak and so when you have include
cs50.h at the top of the file what is
happening when you first run clang
during this so-called pre-processing
step is clang looks on the hard drive
for the file literally called cs50.h it
grabs its contents and essentially finds
and replaces this line here so somewhere
in cs50 h is a line like this yellow one
here that says getstring there is a
function that returns a string and it
takes as input this will called
arguments a string that will call prompt
meanwhile with include standard i/o
what's the point of including that what
is declared inside of that file
presumably yes standard inputs and
outputs and more specifically what
example there of what function yeah so
printf the other function we keep using
so inside of standard IOH somewhere on
the sandbox is hard drive is similarly a
line of code that frankly looks a little
more cryptic but we'll come back to this
sort of thing down the road that says
print F is a function happens to return
an int but more on that another time
happens to take a char star format but
more on that another time indeed this is
one of the reasons we hide this detail
early on because there's some syntax
that's just a distraction for now but
that's all that's going on the sharp
include sign is just finding and
replacing the contents plus dot dot dot
a bunch of other things in those files
as well so when we say pre-processing we
just mean that that's getting
substituted in so you don't have to copy
and paste this sort of thing manually
yourself so compiling is a word that
actually has a well-defined meaning once
you've pre-processed your code and your
code looks essentially like this
unbeknownst to you then comes the actual
compilation step and this code here gets
turned into this code here now this is
scary-looking and this is the sort of
thing that if you take a class like 61
at Harvard or more general
systems programming so to speak you
might see something like this this is
x86 64 bit assembly instructions and the
only thing interesting about that claim
for the moment is that assembly I kind
of alluded to that earlier assembler
output a dot out there's actually a
relationship here but long story short
these are the lower-level instructions
that only the CPU the brain inside your
computer actually understands your CPU
does not understand C doesn't understand
Python or C++ or Java or any language
with it you might be familiar it only
understands this cryptic looking thing
but frankly from the looks of it you
might glean that probably not so much
fun to program in this
I mean arguably it's not that much fun
to program yet in C so this even looks
even more cryptic but that's okay C and
lots of languages are just these
abstractions on top of the lower-level
stuff that the CPUs do actually
understand so that we don't have to
worry about it as much but if we
highlight a few terms here you'll see
some some familiar things so main is
mentioned in this so-called assembly
code you see mention of getstring and
printf so we're not losing information
it's just being presented in really a
different language
assembly language now you can glean
perhaps from some of the names of these
instructions this is what Intel Inside
means when Intel or any brand of CPU
understands instructions it means things
like pushing and moving and subtracting
and calling these are all low-level
verbs functions if you will but at the
level of the CPU but for more on that
you can take entire courses but just to
take the hood off of this for today this
is a step that's been happening for us
magically unbeknownst to us thanks to
clang so assembling now that you've got
this cryptic looking code that we will
never see again we'll never need to
output again what do you do with it well
you said earlier that computers only
understand zeros and ones so the third
step is actually to convert this
assembly language to actual zeros and
ones that now look like this so the
assembling step happening unbeknownst to
you every time you run clang or in turn
run make we're getting zeros and ones
out of the assembly code and we're
getting the assembly code out of your C
code but here's the third or the fourth
and final step recall that we need to
link in other people zeros and ones if
you're using printf you didn't write
that someone else created the
zeros and ones the patterns that the
computer understands you didn't create
getstring we did so you need access to
those zeros and ones so that your
program can use them as well so linking
essentially does this if you've written
a program for instance hello dot C and
it happens to use a couple of other
libraries files that other people wrote
of useful code for you like cs50 dot C
which does exist somewhere and even
standard i/o dot C which does exist
somewhere or technically standard io
such a big library they actually put
printf in a file specifically called
printf dot C but somewhere in the
sandbox is hard drive in all of our Macs
and PCs if they support compiling our
for instance files like these but we've
got to convert this to zeros and ones
this and this and then somehow combine
them so pictorially this just looks a
bit like this and this is all happening
automatically by clang hello dot C the
code you wrote gets compiled to assembly
which then gets assembled into zeros and
ones so called machine code or object
code cs50 dot C we did this for you
before the semester started printf was
done way before any of us started
decades ago and looks like this these
are three separate files though so the
linking step literally means link all of
these things together and combine the
zeros and ones from like three at least
separate files and just combine them in
such a way that now the CPU knows how to
use not just your code but printf and
getstring and so forth so last week we
introduced compiling as an abstraction
if you will and this is all that we've
really meant this whole time but now
that we've seen what's going on
underneath the hood and we can stipulate
that my CPU that looks physically like
this albeit smaller in the laptop or
desktop knows how to deal with all of
that so any questions on these four
steps pre-processing compiling
assembling linking but generally now we
can just call them compiling as most
people do any questions yeah
not in the pre-processing step so the
question is how does the computer know
that printf is the only function that's
there essentially when you're linking in
code only the requisite zeros and ones
are typically linked in sometimes you
get more than you actually need if it's
a big library but that's okay too those
zeros and ones are just never used by
the CPU good question other questions
okay all right so now that we know this
is possible let's start to build our way
back up because everyone here in
probably knows now that when writing in
C which is kind of up here conceptually
like it is not without its hurdles and
problems and bugs and mistakes so let's
introduce a few techniques and tools
with which you can henceforth starting
this we can be on try to troubleshoot
those problems yourself rather than just
trying to read through the cryptic
looking error messages or reach out for
help to another human let's see if
software can actually answer some of
these questions for you so let me go
ahead and do this let me go ahead and
open up a sandbox here and I'm gonna go
ahead and create a new file called buggy
zero dot C in which I will this time
deliberately introduce a bug I'm gonna
go ahead and create my function called
main which is again is the default like
one green flag is clicked and I'm gonna
go ahead and say printf quote unquote
hello world backslash n all right looks
pretty good I'm gonna go ahead and
compile buggy zero enter and of course I
get a bunch of error messages here let
me zoom in on them fortunately I only
have two but remember you have to have
to have to always scroll up to look at
the first because there might just be an
annoying cascading effect from one
earlier bug to the later
so buggy zero dot c9 five is what this
means character five so like five spaces
in implicitly declaring library function
printf with dot dot dot so you're gonna
start to see this pretty often if you
make this particular mistake or
oversight implicitly declaring something
means you forgot to teach clang that
something exists and you probably know
from experience perhaps now what the
solution is what's the first mistake I
made here
yeah I didn't include the header file so
to speak for the library I'm missing at
the top of the file include standard IOH
in which printf is defined but let's
propose that you're not quite sure how
to get to that point and how can we get
actually some help with this let me
actually increase the size of my
terminal here and recall that just a
moment ago I ran make buggy 0 which
yielded the errors that I saw it turns
out that installed in the sandbox is a
command that we the staff wrote called
help 50 and this is just a program we
wrote that takes as input any error
messages that your code or some program
has outputted we kind of look for
familiar words and phrases just like a
TF would in office hours and if we
recognize some error message we're gonna
try to provide either rhetorically or
explicitly some advice on how to handle
so if I go ahead and run this command
now notice there's a bit more output I
see exactly the same output in white and
green and red as before but down below
is some yellow which comes specifically
from help 50 and if I go ahead and zoom
in on this you'll see that the line of
output that we recognised is this one
that same one I met a verbally drew
attention to before buggy 0.05 error
implicitly declaring library function
printf and so forth so here without the
background highlighting but still in
yellow is our advice or our a question
at C F for C a might ask you in office
hours
well did you forget to include standard
IOH in which printf is declared atop
your file and hopefully our questions
rhetorical or otherwise are correct and
that'll get you further along so let's
go ahead and try that advice so include
standard IOH now let me go ahead and go
back down here and if you like if you
don't like clutter you can type clear or
hit ctrl L in the terminal window to
keep cleaning it like I do if you want
to go ahead now and run make buggy zero
enter fewer errors so that's progress
and not the same so this one's perhaps a
little easier reading the line what mine
of code is buggy here yeah so this is
now still on line five it turns out but
for a different reason I seem to be
missing a semicolon but I could
similarly ask help 50 for help with that
and hope that it recognizes my error so
this too should start being your first
instinct if on first glance you don't
really understand what an air
message is doing even though you've
scroll to the very first one like
literally asked this program for help by
rerunning the exact same command you
just ran but prefix it with help 50 and
a space and that will run help 50 for
you any questions on that process
alright let's take a look at one other
program for instance that this time has
a different error involved in it so how
about let me go ahead and whip up a
quick program here I'll call this buggy
2 dot C for consistency with some of the
samples we have online for you later and
in this example I'm gonna go ahead and
write the correct thing at first
standard IO dot H and then I'm gonna
have int main void which just gets my
whole program started and then I'm gonna
have a loop and recall from excuse me
Mario or some other program you might
have done something like int I get 0 I
is less than or equal to let's do this
10 times and then I plus plus and all I
want to do in this program is print out
that value of I as I can do with the
percent I placeholder so simple program
just wanted to count from 0 to 10 so
let's go ahead and run buggy 2 or rather
I want to I want to let's not print up
huh rewind let's go ahead and just print
out a hash symbol and not spoil the
solution this way so here I go ahead and
print out buggy to my goal is now I will
stipulate to print out just 10 hash
symbols one per line which is what I
want to do here and now I'm going to go
ahead and run up slash buggy 2 and I
should see hopefully 10 hashes alright
and I kind of spoiled this a little bit
but what do I instead see yeah I think I
see more than I expect and we can kind
of zoom in here and double check so 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 11 now some of your
eyes might already be darting to what
the solutions should be but let's just
propose that it's non-obvious and if it
is actually non-obvious all the better
so how might you go about diagnosing
this kind of problem short of just
reaching out and asking a human for help
this is not a problem that help 50 can
help with because it's not an error
message your program is work
it's just not outputting what you wanted
it to work but it's not an error message
from the compiler with which help 50 can
help so you want to kind of get eyes
into what your program is doing and you
want to understand why are you printing
11 when you really are setting this up
from 0 to 10 well one of the most common
techniques in C or any language honestly
is to use printf for just other purposes
diagnostic purposes for instance there's
not much going on in this program but
I'd argue that it would be interesting
for me to know and therefore understand
my program by just let's print out this
value of I on each iteration as by doing
the line of code that I earlier did and
just say something literally like I is
percent I like I'm gonna remove this
ultimately because it's gonna make my
program look a little silly but it's
gonna help me understand what's going on
let me go ahead and recompile buggy 2
dot slash buggy 2 and this time I see a
lot more output but if i zoom in now
it's kind of now the computer is
essentially helping me understand what's
going on when I is zero here's one of
them when I is one here's another is 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and that looks good but if
we scroll a little further feels a
little problematic that I can also be 10
so what's logically the bug in this
program yeah I used less than or equal
to because I kind of confused the
paradigm right like programmers tend to
start counting at zero apparently but I
want to do this 10 times and in the
human world if I want to do something 10
times I might count up to and including
10 but you can't have it both ways you
can't start at zero and end at 10 if you
want to do something exactly 10 times so
where there's a couple of possibilities
here how might we fix this yeah so we
could certainly change it to less than
what's another correct approach yeah so
we could leave this alone and just start
counting at 1 and if you're not actually
printing the values in your actual
program that might be perfectly
reasonable to uh it's just not
conventional like get comfortable with
quickly just counting from 0 because
that's just what most everyone does
these days but technique here is just
use printf like when in doubt literally
use printf on this line on this line on
this line anywhere something is
interesting may be going on in your
program just use it to print out the
strings that are in your very
print out the I have the integers that
are in your variables or anything else
and it allows you to kind of see so to
speak what's going on inside of your
program printf alright one last tool so
it's not uncommon when writing code to
maybe get a little sloppy early on
especially when you're not quite
familiar with the patterns and for
instance if I go ahead and do this by
deleting a whole bunch of whitespace
even after fixing this mistake by going
from zero to ten is this program now
correct if the goal is to print ten
hashes yeah yes why is it correct in
what sense yeah exactly it still works
it prints out the ten hashes one per
line but it's poorly written in the
sense of style so recall that we tend to
evaluate and the world tends to think
about code in at least three ways one
the correctness does it do what it's
supposed to do like print ten hashes and
yes it does because all I did was delete
whitespace I didn't actually change or
break the code after making that fix to
is designed like how thoughtful how
well-written is the code and frankly
it's kind of hard to write this in too
many ways because it's so few lines but
you'll see over time as your programs
grow the Teaching Fellows and staff can
provide you with feedback on the design
of your code but style is relatively
easy and I've been teaching it mostly by
way of example if you will cuz I've been
very methodically indenting my code and
making sure everything kind of looks
very pretty or at least pretty to a
trained eye but this let's just
stipulate is not pretty like left
aligning everything still works not
incorrect but it's poorly styled and
what would be an argument for not
writing code like this and instead
writing code the way I did a moment ago
albeit after fixing the bug yeah
exactly let me summarize this it allows
you to see more visually what are the
individual subroutines or blocks of code
doing that are associated with each
other right scratch is colorful and it
has shapes like the the hugging shape
that a lot of the control blocks make to
make clear visually to the programmer
that this block encompasses others and
therefore this repeats block or this
forever block is doing these things
again and again and again that's the
role that these curly braces serve an
indentation in this and another context
just helps it become more obvious to the
programmer what is inside of what and
what is happening where so this is just
better written because you can see that
the code inside of main is everything
that's indented here the code that's
inside the for loop is everything that's
indented here so it's just for us human
readers teaching fellows in the case of
the course or colleagues in the case of
the real world but suppose that you
don't quite see these patterns to
readily initially that too is fine cs50
has on its website what we call a style
guide it's just a summary of what your
code should look like when using certain
features of C loops conditions variables
functions and so forth and it's linked
on the courses website but there's also
a tool that you can use when writing
your code that'll help you clean it up
and make it consistent not just for the
sake of making consistent with the style
guide but just making your own code
readable more readable so for instance
if I go ahead and run a command called
style 50 on this program buggy to dot C
and then hit enter I'm gonna see some
output that's colorful I see my own code
in white and then I see any where I
should have indented green spaces that
are sort of encouraging me put space
space space space here put space space
space space here put eight spaces here
four spaces here and so forth and then
it's reminding me I should add comments
as well this is a short program doesn't
necessarily need a lot of commenting to
explain what's going on but just one
slash slash like we saw last week to
explain maybe at the top of the file or
top the block of the code would make
style 50 happy as well so let's do that
let me go ahead and take its advice and
actually indent this with tab this with
tab this would tab this would tab and
this once more and you'll notice that on
your keyboard even though you're hitting
tab it's actually converting it for you
which is very common to for spaces so
you don't have to hit the spacebar for
just get into the habit of using tab and
let me go ahead and write a comments
here print ten hashes this way my
colleagues my Teaching Fellow myself in
a week don't have to read my own code
again and figure out what it's doing I
can read the comments alone / the / / if
I run style 50 again now it looks good
it's in accordance with the style guide
and it's just more prettily written so
pretty printed would be a term of art in
programming when your code looks good
and isn't just correct any questions
yeah that's it wasn't enabled for the
first week of the class it's enabled as
of right now and henceforth other
questions all right so just to recap
then three tools to have in the
proverbial toolbox now our help 50
anytime you see an error message that
you don't understand whether it's with
make or clang or perhaps something else
printf when you've got a logical program
a bug in your program it's just not
working the way it's supposed to or the
way the the problems that tells you it
should and then style 50 when you want
to make sure that it does my code look
right in terms of style and is it as
readable as possible and honestly you'll
find us at office hours and the like
often encouraging you hey before we
answer this question can you please run
style 50 on your code can you please
clean up your code because it just makes
our lives to is other humans so much
easier one we can understand what's
going on without having to visually
figure out what parentheses and curly
braces line up and so do get into that
habit because will save you time from
having to waste time parsing things
visually yourself
alright so there's not just CPUs and
computers CPUs are the brains central
processing unit and that's why we keep
emphasizing the instructions that
computers understand there's also this
which we saw last time - this is an
example of what type of hardware RAM or
random access memory this is the type of
memory that laptops desktops servers
have that is used whenever you run a
program or open a file there's another
type of memory called hard drives or
solid-state drives which you're probably
familiar as a consumer and that's just
where your files are stored permanently
you can your battery can die you can
pull the plug from your laptop or
desktop and any file saved on a hard
drive are persistent they stay there
because of the technology being used to
implement that but
Ram is more ephemeral Ram is powered
only by electricity it's only used when
the power is on or the battery is
charged and it's where your files and
programs live effectively when you
double-click on them and open them so
when you double-click on something like
Microsoft Word it is copied from your
hard drive long term into this type of
memory because this type of memory those
smaller in capacity you don't have as
many bytes of it but it is much much
much much faster similarly when you open
a document or you go to a web page the
contents of the file you're seeing are
stored in this type of hardware because
even though you don't have terribly many
bytes of it it's just much much much
much faster and so this will be thematic
in computer science and in Hardware you
sort of have lots of cheap slow stuff
like hard disk space relatively speaking
and you have a little less of the more
expensive but faster stuff like RAM and
you have just one usually CPU which is
the really fast thing that can do a
billion things per second but it too is
more expensive so there's four visible
chips on this thing if you will and we
won't get into the details of how these
things work but let's just zoom in on
this one black chip here and focus on it
as being representative is some amount
of memory maybe it's one megabyte 1
million bytes maybe it's even one
gigabyte these days 1 billion bytes but
this is to say that this chip can be
thought of as just having a bunch of
bytes in it this is not to scale you
have many more bytes than these but let
me propose that you just think of each
of these squares here is representing
one byte so the very first byte of
memory I have access to us here next one
is here and so forth and the fact that
they wrap around is just an artist's
rendition these things you can think of
just virtually is going left to right
not in any kind of grid but physically
they look like this so when you actually
create a variable in a program like C
like you need a char a char tends to be
one byte or eight bits and so that means
when you have a variable of type char in
a C program it goes literally physically
in one of these boxes inside of your
computer's Ram so for instance it might
take up this much space at top left if
you have a bigger type of data so you
have an integer which tends to be 4
bytes or 32 bits you might need more
than one square so the computer might
give you access to four squares instead
and you have the
two bits spanning that region of memory
but honestly I chose those boxes
arbitrarily they could be anywhere in
that chip or in any of the other chips
it's up to the computer to just remember
where they are for you you don't need to
remember that per se but if we think
about this grid it turns out this is
actually very valuable that we have
chunks of memory bytes if you will that
are back to back to back to back and in
fact there's a word for this technique
this is contiguous memory back to back
to back to back to back and in general
in programming this is referred to as an
array
you might recall from scratch if you use
this feature it actually has things
called lists which are exactly that
lists of values lists of words lists of
strings an array is just a contiguous
chunk of memory such that you can store
something hear something hear something
hear something hear and so forth so it
turns out an array this super simple
primitive is actually incredibly
powerful just being able to store things
in my computer's memory
back-to-back-to-back-to-back enable so
many possibilities both design-wise like
how well I can write my code and also
how fast I can make my code run so let
me go ahead and take out an example let
me go ahead and open up for instance a
new file in a sandbox and we'll call
this scores zero so let me go ahead and
close this one create a new file called
scores zero dot C and in this file let's
go ahead and write a relatively simple
program let me go ahead and as usual
give myself access to some helpful
functions cs50.h
and standard IO dot H and no need to
copy all this down verbatim if you don't
like everything will have or is already
on the courses website let me start my
program as usual with int main void and
then let me write a program as this
programs name implies that like asks the
user for three scores on recent problem
sets quizzes whatever and then kind of
creates a very simple chart of them like
a bar chart to kind of help me visualize
how how well or how poorly I did on
something so if I want to get an integer
no surprise we can use the get int
function and I can just ask the user for
their first score but I should probably
do something with this score and on the
left hand side of this what do I
typically put yeah so int sure score 1
equals this and then my semicolon so you
might not have had many occasions to use
in just yet but get int is in the cs50
library this is the so-called prompt
that the human sees and let me actually
fix my space because I want the human to
see the space after the colon but that's
just an aesthetic detail and then when I
get back this value but its return value
just like Aaron last week handed me a
piece of paper so does get in hand me a
virtual piece of paper with a number
that I'm gonna store in a variable
called score one and now just to be
clear what has just happened effectively
is this the moment you create a variable
of type int which is 4 bytes literally
this is what clang or more generally the
computer has done for you that int that
the human typed in is stored literally
in four contiguous bytes back to back to
back maybe here maybe here but together
so that's all that's going on when
you're actually using C so let me go
back into my code here and now I wanna
it's not interesting to plot one score
so let's go ahead and do another so int
score to get int get int and I'll ask
the user for score two semicolon and
then let's get one more score three get
into call it score three semicolon
alright so now let me go ahead and
generate like a bar like a bar chart of
this I'm gonna use what we'll call ASCII
art ASCII of course is just text recall
very simple text in the computer and you
know what I can kind of make a bar chart
pretty simply by just printing out like
a bunch of hashes horizontally so a
short bar will represent a small number
and a long bar will represent a big
number so let me go ahead and say to the
user all right here's your score one I'm
gonna go ahead then and say for int I
get 0 I is less than score 1 I plus plus
and now if I scroll down and give myself
a bit of room here let me go ahead and
implement just a simple print so go
ahead and print out a hash and then when
you're all done with that print out a
new line at the end of that loop and
let's just pause there just to recap
I've asked the human for three scores
I'm only doing something with one of
them at the moment so in fact just as a
quick check let me delete those so it's
do not get ahead of myself let me do
make score zero cross my fingers okay no
errors now let me go ahead and do dots
scores zero and your first score on a
pset this year ahead of hundred has been
okay a hundred and good job so it's a
really long bar and if we count those up
hopefully there's actually a hundred
bars and if we run it again and say it
didn't go so well I got a fifty that's
half as big a bar so it seems like we're
on our way
correctness wise so now let me go ahead
and get the other scores well I had them
here a moment ago so let me go ahead and
just well you know kind of copy paste
and change this to two change this to
three change this to three this to three
all right I know how to print bars
clearly so let me go ahead and do this
and then do this and then fix the
indentation I don't want to say score
one everywhere I want to say score two
score too I mean you're probably being
rubbed the wrong way that this is both
tedious and sloppy and why what am i
doing poorly now design-wise my
copy-pasting almost always bad right
there's redundancy here but that's fine
let's prioritize correctness at least
for now so let me go ahead and make
score zero all right no mistakes dot
slash score zero and the penet and let
me go ahead now and run okay we got a
hundred the first time we got fifty this
oh that's a bug what did i do there see
this is what happens when you copy paste
so let's fix this that should say score
two so ctrl C will quit a program make
score zero will recreate it dot slash
score zero enter all right here we go
150 let's split the difference 75 all
right so this is a simple bar chart
horizontally drawn of each of my three
scores where this is 100 this is 50 and
this is 75 but there's opportunities for
improvement here so one it rubbed some
folks the wrong way already that's we
were really copying and pasting code so
where's one opportunity for improvement
here what should I do instead of copying
and pasting that code again and again
what ingredient can you bring ok so we
could use a loop and actually just do
the same thing three times so let's try
that let me go ahead and do this so
let's go ahead and delete the copy paste
I did and let me go ahead and say okay
well for int I get 0
I less than three I plus plus let me
create a bracket I can highlight
multiple lines and hit tab and they'll
all indent for me which is convenient
and can I do this now for instance say a
little letter
yeah it's I am a little worried as
you're noting here we're using on line
13 here the same variable so like so
it's good instincts but I feel like the
fact that this program unlike last week
we're now collecting multiple pieces of
data loops are breaking down for us yeah
okay okay
yeah we could implement another function
that factors out some of this
functionality and other thoughts okay so
we could also store our scores in an
array so let's do these in order than in
fact so loops are wonderful when you
want to do something again and again and
again but the whole purpose of a
function fundamentally is to factor out
common functionality and there might
still be a loop in the solution but the
real fundamental problem with what I was
doing a moment ago was I was copying and
pasting functionality shouldn't need to
do that because in both C and scratch we
had the ability to make our own
functions so let's do that let me undo
my loop changes here just to get us back
to where we were a moment ago and let me
go ahead and instead clean this up a
little bit let me go ahead and create a
new function down here that I'm gonna
call say chart just to create a chart
for myself and it's gonna take as input
a score but I could call this anything I
want it's void as its return type
because I don't need it to hand me
something back like I'm not getting a
string from the user I'm just printing a
chart it's a so-called side effect or
output all right now I'm gonna go ahead
and do my loop here for int I get 0 I is
less than how many hashes do I want to
print if I'm being passed in the user
score like is this 3 here user score so
if I'm being handed a number that's 0 to
100 that's what I want to iterate over
if my goal here ultimately let me finish
this thought I plus plus is 2 inside
this loop print out one hash per point
in one's total score and just to keep
things clean I'm gonna go ahead and put
a new line at the very end of this but I
think now I factored out a good amount
of the redundancy it's not everything
but I've at least now given myself a
function called chart so up here it
looks like I can kind of remove this
loop which is what I factored out that's
almost identical except the variable
name was hard-coded and I think I could
now do chart like this and then I maybe
could do a little copy-paste if that's
okay like if maybe I can get away with
just doing this and then say 2 and then
say 3 and then say 3 and then say 2 so
it's it's still copy/paste but it's less
and it looks better it literally fits on
the screen so it's progress not perfect
but progress better
but not perfect so is this gonna compile
I'm gonna have errors why okay yeah
okay good sewing let me in deuce the
actual error just so we know what
problem we're solving let me go ahead
and sort of innocently go ahead and
compile scores zero hoping all as well
but of course it's not because of a
familiar error up here
so notice implicit declaration a
function chart is invalid in c99 so
again implicit declaration of function
just tends to mean clang does not know
what you're talking about and you could
run help 50 and it would probably
provide you with similar advice but the
gist of this is that chart is not a C
function it doesn't come with C I wrote
it I just wrote it a little too late so
one solution that we didn't use last
week would be okay well if you don't
know what chart is let me just go put it
where you'll know about it and now run
make score zero okay problem solved so
that fixes it but we fixed it in a
different way last week and why might we
want to stick with last week's approach
and not just copy paste my function and
put it at the top instead of the bottom
yeah I mean it's kind of a minor concern
at the moment because this is a pretty
short program but I'm pushing like the
main part of my program literally called
main farther and farther down and like
the whole point of reading code is to
understand what it's doing so if I open
this file and I have to scroll Scroll
scroll Scroll scroll just looking for
the main function like that's just bad
styles it's just kind of nice and it's a
good human convention put the main code
the main function when green flag
clicked s-- equivalent at the very top
so c does offer us a solution here you
just have to provide it with a little
hint let me go ahead and cut this from
here put it back down at the bottom here
and then go ahead and copy paste only or
retype only the value ups the value of
that first line which is its so-called
prototype give clang enough information
so that it knows what arguments the
function takes what its return type is
and what its name is
semicolon and that's the so-called
declaration or and then implement it
with the curly braces and all the logic
down below so let's go ahead and run
this and if I scroll up here we'll see
whips we'll see make score zero all
right now we're on our
'we score zero enter score 1 is 150 75
and now we seem to have some good
functionality but there's still an
opportunity i daresay for improvement
and i think the fundamental problem is
that i'm still copy pasting a little
stuff but i think the fundamental
problem is that i don't have the
expressiveness to store multiple values
unless i in advance as the programmer
give them all unique names because if i
use the same variable for everything i
couldn't collect all three variables at
the top and then iterate over all three
at the bottom if i only have one
variable so I do need three variables
but this doesn't scale very well and who
knows if I want to take in five scores
10 scores or Moriscos scores then I'm
really copying and pasting excessively
so it turns out indeed the answer is an
array so an array at the end of the day
is just a a side-effect of storing stuff
and memory back to back to back to back
but what's powerful about this reality
of memory is the following I can go
ahead here and in say a new and more
improved version of this program do this
let me go ahead and open this one which
I wrote in advance called scores to see
and in scores 2 dot C notice we have the
following code in my main function I've
got a new feature and a new bit of
syntax this line here that I've
highlighted says hey clang give me a
variable called scores of type integer
but please give me three of them so the
new syntax here are square brackets and
inside of which is the number of
variables you want of that type and you
don't have to give them a unique names
you literally call them collectively
scores and in English I deliberately
chose a plural to connote as much this
is a an array of values not a single
value what can I do next well here's my
for loop for int I get 0 is less than 3
i plus plus and now I've solved that
earlier problem that was proposed well
just put it in a loop now I can because
now my variables are not called score
one score two score three which I
literally had to hard-code
they're just called scores and now that
they're called scores and I have this
square bracket notation notice what I
can do I can get an int and I can say
give me score percent I and plug-in I
plus one I didn't want to say zero
because humans don't count from zero in
general so this is counting from
one two and three but the computer is
doing this so scores is a variable
bracket I close bracket says store the
eighth value there so I fizz just non
English that means go to bracket zero
bracket one bracket two so what this
effectively means is on the first
iteration of this loop when I equals
zero this looks like this effectively
when I then becomes one on the next
iteration then you're doing this when I
becomes two on the final iteration it
looks like this when I becomes three
while three is not less than three and
so it doesn't execute again so by using
I inside of these parentheses square
brackets am i indexing into an array to
index into an array means go to a
specific location the so-called ice
location but you start counting at zero
just to make this more real then if you
go back to this picture of your
computer's memory this might therefore
be bracket I bracket one from bracket
zero bracket one bracket two bracket 3
bracket four back at fifty or wherever
you can now using square brackets get at
any of these blocks of memory to store
values for you are any questions on what
we've just done all right then on the
flip side we can do the exact same thing
now when I print my scores I can
similarly iterate from zero to three and
then print out the scores by passing to
chart the same value the I score again
the only new syntax here is variable
name square bracket and then a number
like zero one two or a variable like I
and then my chart function down here is
exactly the same it has no ID and array
is even involved because I'm just
passing in one score at a time now turns
out there's still one bad design
decision in this program there's still
some redundancy something that I keep
typing again and again and again
do any values jump out at you as
repeated
the for-loop okay so I've got the for
loop in multiple places sure and what
other value seems to be in multiple
places it's subtle total number yeah
three like three is in a few places it's
up here it's when I declare the very the
array and guess myself for three scores
it's here when I'm iterating it's here
when I'm interning it's not here because
this is a different iteration that's
just for the hashes so in Iran eclis
three places have I written three so
what does this mean well suppose next
year you take more tests or whatever and
you need more scores you open up your
program and all right now I've got five
scores and five Oh ups see a typo
already five like this kind of pattern
where you're typing the same thing again
and again and now the onus is on me the
programmer to remember to change the
same damn value in multiple places like
bad bad bad design
you're gonna miss one of those values
your program is going to get more
complex you're going to leave one at
three and change the other to five and
like logical errors are eventually going
to happen so how do we solve this if
functions not the solution here because
it's not functionality it's just a value
well we could use a variable but a
certain type of variable these numbers
here five five five or three three three
or what humans generally refer to as
magic numbers like they're numbers but
they're kind of magical because you've
just arbitrarily hard-coded them in
random places but a better convention
would be often as a global variable to
do this int let's call it count equals
three so declare a variable of type int
that is the number of things you want
and then type that variable name all
throughout your code so that later on if
you ever want to change this program you
change it whoops in one place and you're
done after recompiling the program and
actually I should do a little better
than this it turns out that if you know
you have a variable that you're never
gonna change because it's not supposed
to change its supposed to be a constant
value C also has a special keyword
called Const where before the datatype
you say Const int and then the name and
then the value and this way the compiler
clang will make sure that you the human
don't screw up and accidentally try to
change the count anywhere else there's
one other thing notable I also
capitalize this whole thing for some
reason human convention anytime
capitalize all of the letters in a
variable name the convention is that
that means it's global that means it's
defined way up top and you can use it
anywhere therefore because it's outside
all curly braces but it's meant to imply
and remind you that this is special it's
not just a so-called local variable
inside of a function or inside of a loop
or the like any questions on this yeah
oh why do I have I hon let me run this
program real quick
why do I have I play in this lines here
is the question so let me go ahead and
run make scores to whoops in my
directory make scores to dot slash
scores to enter I wanted just the human
to see score one and score two and score
three I didn't want him or her to see
like score zero score one score two
because it just looks lame to the human
the computer needs to think in terms of
zeros my humans and my users like do not
so just an aesthetic other questions
yeah
a really good question so and I actually
thought about this last night when
trying to when trying to craft this
example why don't I just combine these
two for loops because they're clearly
iterating an identical number of times
was this a hand or just a stretch
stretch so this is actually deliberate
if I combine these what would what would
change logically in my program yeah yeah
so after every human input of a score I
would see that users chart the run row
of hashes then I'd ask them for another
value they'd see the chart another value
and they'd see the chart and that's fine
like if that is the design you want
totally acceptable totally correct I
wanted mine to look a little more
traditional with all of the bars
together so I effectively had to
postpone printing the hashes and that's
why I did have a little bit of
redundancy by getting the users input
here and then iterating again to
actually print the users output as a
chart so just a design decision good
question other questions all right so
what does this look like actually you
know what I can probably do a little
better let me open up one final example
involving scores and this thing called
an array in scores for here let me go
ahead and do this now I've changed my
chart function to do a little bit more
and you might recall from week 0 and 1
we had the COFF function and we kept
enhancing it to do more and more like
putting more and more logic into it
notice this chart function now takes a
second argument which is kind of
interesting it takes one argument which
is a number and then the next argument
is an array of scores so long story
short if you want to have a function
that takes as input an array you don't
have to know in advance how big that
array is you should not in fact put a
number in between the square brackets in
this context but the thing is you do
need to know at some point how many
items are in the array if you've
programmed in Java took APCs Java just
gives you dot length if you're recall
that feature of objects C does not have
this arrays do not have an inherent
length associated with them you have to
tell everyone who uses your array how
long it is so even though you don't do
that syntactically here you literally
just say IX
an argument called scores that is an
array per the square brackets you have
to pass in almost always a second
variable that is literally called
whatever you want but is the number of
things in that array because if the goal
of this function is just to iterate over
the number of scores that are passed in
and then iterate over the number of
points in that score in order to print
out the hashes you need to know this
count so what does this function do just
to be clear this iterates over the total
number of scores from zero to count
which is probably three or five or
whatever this loop here using J which is
just a convention instead iterates from
zero to whatever that score is so this
is what's convenient now I've passed in
the array and I can still get at
individual values just by using I
because I'm on my I fit eration here so
you might recall this from Mario for
instance or any other example in which
you had nested loops just very
conventional to use I on the outside J
on the inside but again the only point
here is that you can indeed pass around
arrays even as arguments which we'll see
why that's useful before long any
questions okay so this was a lot but we
can do so much more still with arrays
they could even more and more cool in
fact we'll see in just a bit how arrays
have actually been with us since last
week we just didn't quite realize it
under the hood but let's go ahead and
take a breather five minutes we'll come
back and dive in all right so I know
that was a bit of a cliffhanger where
else could arrays have actually been but
of course this is how we might depicted
pictorially we called it an array and it
turns out that last week when we
introduced strings strings sequences of
characters are literally just an array
by another name a string it is an array
of chars and chars of course is another
data type now what are the actual
implications of this both in terms of
representation like how computer is
representing information and then to
fundamentally programmatically what can
we do when we know all of our data is so
back-to-back-to-back or so proximal to
one another well it turns out that we
can apply this logic in a few different
ways let me go ahead and open up for
instance
it's example here called string zero so
in our code for today and our source to
folder let me go ahead and open up
string zero and this example looks like
this
notice that we first on line nine get a
string from the user just say input
please we store that value in a string s
and then we say here comes the output
and notice what I'm doing in the
following line I'm iterating over I from
zero to sterling s whatever that is and
then in line thirteen I'm printing a
character one at a time but notice the
syntax I'm using which we didn't use
last week if you have a string called s
you can index into a string just like
it's an array because it indeed is
underneath the hood so s bracket I where
I starts at zero and goes up to whatever
this value is is just a way of getting
character 0 then character 1 then
character 2 then character 3 and so the
end result is actually gonna look like
this let me go ahead and do make string
whoops make string 0 oops not in the
directory make string string 0 dot slash
string 0 enter and I'll type in say
zamyla and the output now is Z am yla
it's a little messy because I don't have
a new line here so let me actually let's
clean that up because this is
unnecessarily sloppy so let me go ahead
and print out a new line let me
recompile with make string 0 dot whoops
dot slash string 0 input shall be simila
enter and now Z am y la so why is that
happening well if I scroll down on this
code it seems that I am via this printf
line here just getting the ithe
character of the name in s and then
printing out one character at a time per
the percent C followed by a new line so
you might guess what is this function
here doing ster Lang slightly
abbreviated but you can perhaps glean
what it means yeah so it's actually
string length so it turns out there is a
function that comes with C called
sterling and humans back in the day and
to this
they like to type as few characters when
possible and so sterling is
string-length and the way you use it is
you just need one more header file so
there's another library the so called
string library that gives you string
related functions beyond what cs50 s
library provides and so if you include
string dot H that gives you access to
another function called ster Lang that
if you pass it a variable containing a
string it will pass you back as a return
value the total number of characters so
I typed in Z am y la and so that should
be returning to me 6 thereby printing
out the six characters in this Amaya's
name yeah uh-huh really good question in
the credit problem of the problem said
would this have been useful yes
absolutely but recall that in the credit
pset we encouraged you to actually take
in the number as a long so as an
integral value which thereby
necessitated arithmetic but yes if you
had instead in a problem involving
credit card numbers gotten the humans
input as a long string of characters and
not as an actual number like an int or
long then yes you could actually get at
those individual characters would
probably would have made things even
easier but deliberate yeah
really good question if we're defining
string and cs50 are we redefining it in
string no so string even though its name
string H doesn't actually define
something called a string it just has
string related functions more than that
soon yeah really good question could you
edit the individual values so short
answer yes we could absolutely change
values and will soon do that in another
context other questions
all right so turns out this is correct
if my goal is to print out all of the
characters in zamyla's name but it's not
the best design and this one's a little
subtle but this is again what we mean by
design into a question that came up
during the break did we expect everyone
to be writing good style and good design
last week like know up until today like
we've introduced the notion of
correctness in both scratch and incy
last week but now we're introducing
these other axes of quality of code like
design how well-designed is it is and
how pretty does it look in the context
of style so expectations are here on out
meant to be aligned with those those
characteristics but not not in the past
so there's a slight inefficiency here so
on the first iteration of this loop I
first initialize I to 0 and then I check
if I is less than the length of the
string which hopefully it is if it's
zamyla which is longer than 0 then I
print the 8th character then I increment
I then I check this condition then I
print the ithe character then I
increment I then I check this condition
and so forth we loop through loops last
we can you've used them perhaps by now
in problems what question and I am i
redundantly asking seemingly
unnecessarily I have to check a
condition again and again because I is
getting incremented but there's another
other question that I don't need to keep
asking again just to get the same answer
yeah there's this function call in my
loop of sterling s which is fine this is
correct I'm checking the length of the
string but once I type in zamyla her
name is not changing in length I'm
incrementing I so I'm moving in the
string if you will but the string itself
za my la is not changing
so why am i asking the computer again
and again
get me the Sterling of s get me the
Sterling of s get me the Sterling of s
so I can actually fix this I can improve
the design because that must take some
amount of time maybe it's fast but it's
still a non-zero amount of time so you
know what I could do I could do
something like this int n gets string
length of s and now just do this this
would be better design because now I'm
only asking the question once of the
function I'm remembering or cashing if
you will the answer and then I'm just
using a variable and just comparing
variables is just faster than comparing
a variable against a function which has
to be called which has to return a value
which you can then compare but honestly
it doesn't have to be this verbose we
can actually be a little elegant about
this if you're using a loop a secret
feature of loops is that you can have
commas after declaring variables and you
can actually do this and make this even
more elegant if you will or more
confusing looking depending on your
perspective but this now does the same
thing but declares n inside of the loop
just like I'm declaring I and it's just
a little tighter it's one fewer lines of
code any questions then good question in
the way I've just done it cannot reuse
this outside of the curly braces the
scope of I and N exists only in this
context right now the other way yes I
could have used it elsewhere
absolutely
correct if I want to use the length of s
again absolutely I can declare the
variable or as I did earlier outside of
the loop so as to reuse it that's
totally fine yes
and even I I exists only inside of this
loop so if I have another loop I can
reuse I and it's a different I because
these variables only exist inside the
for loop in which they're declared so it
turns out that these strings don't have
anything in them other than character
after character after character and in
fact let me go ahead here and draw a
picture of what's actually going on
underneath the hood of the computer here
so when I type in zamyla's name I'm of
course doing something like Z a M Y L a
but where is that actually going well we
know now that inside of your computer is
RAM or memory and you can think of it
like a grid and honestly I can think of
this whole screen as just being in a
different orientation a grid of memory
so for instance maybe we can divide it
into rows and columns like this not
necessarily to scale and it's more rows
and columns so on the screen here I'm
just dividing things into the individual
bytes of memory that we saw a moment ago
and so indeed underneath the hood of the
computer is this layout of memory the
compiler has somehow figured out or the
program has somehow figured out where to
put the Z and where the a and then the M
and the Y and the L in the a but the key
is that they're all contiguous back to
back to back but the catch is if I'm
typing other words into my program or
scores into my program or any data into
my program it's gonna end up elsewhere
in the computer's memory so how do you
know where zamyla begins and where
zamyla ends so to speak in memory
well the variable called s essentially
is here there's some remembrance in the
computer of where S begins but there's
no obvious way to know where zamyla ends
unless we ourselves tell the computer so
unbeknownst to us anytime a computer is
storing a string like Z a my la turns
out that it's not using one two three
four five six characters it's actually
using seven secretly it's actually
putting a special character of all 0
in the very last bite every byte is
eight bits so it's putting secretly
eight zeros there or we can actually
draw this more conventionally as
backslash zero is what's called the null
character and it just means all zeros so
the length of the string zamyla is six
but how many bytes does it apparently
take up just to be clear so it actually
takes up seven and this is kind of a
secret implementation detail that we
don't really have to care about but
eventually we will because if we want to
implement certain functionality we're
gonna need to know what is actually
going on so for instance let me go ahead
and do this let me go ahead and create a
program called Stirling itself so this
is not a function but a program called
string length dot C let me go ahead and
include the cs50 library at the top let
me go ahead and include standard IOH let
me go ahead and type out int main void
so all this is same as always and then
let me go ahead and prompt the user for
say his or her name like so and then you
know what let me actually this time not
just print their name out because we've
done that ad nauseam let's just count
the number of letters in his or her name
so how could we do that well we could
just do this int n gets sterling of s
and then say printf the length of your
name is % I and then we can plug in n
because that's the number we stored the
length in but to use sterling I have to
include what header file string dot H
which is the new one so string dot H and
now if I type this all correctly make
ster Lang make ster Lang good dot slash
sterling let's try it
zamyla enter ok the length of her name
is six but what is sterling doing well
sterling is just an abstraction for us
that someone else wrote and it's
wonderfully convenient but you know we
don't strictly need it I can actually do
this myself if I understand what the
computer is doing
I can implement this same functionality
myself as follows I can declare a
variable called N and initialize it to
zero and then you know what I'm going to
go ahead and do this while s bracket n
does not equal all zeros but you don't
write all zeros like this you literally
do this that backslash zero two which I
referred earlier in single quotes that
just means all
in the bite and now I can go ahead and
do n plus plus if unfamiliar with what
this means remember that this is just N
equals n plus 1 but it's just a little
more compact to say n plus plus and then
I can print out the name of your N or
the name of your n and the name of your
the length of your name is % i plugging
in n so why does this work it's a little
funky looking but this is just
demonstrating an understanding of what's
going on underneath the proverbial hood
if n is initialized to 0 and I look at s
bracket n well that's like looking at s
bracket 0 and if the string s is zamyla
what is s bracket 0 Z and then it does
not equal backslash 0 it equals Z
obviously so we increment n so now n is
1 now n is 1 so what is s bracket 1 in
zamyla's name a and so forth and we get
to za
and y la then all zeroes the so-called
null character or backslash 0 that of
course does equal backslash 0 so the
loop stops there by leaving the total
count or value of n at what it
previously was which was 6 so that's it
like all underneath the hood all we have
is like memory laid out like this top to
bottom left to right and yet all of the
functionality we've been using for a
week now and henceforth just boils down
to some relatively simple primitives and
if you understand those primitives like
you can do anything you want using the
computer both computationally code wise
but also memory wise we can actually see
in fact some of the stuff we looked at
two weeks ago as follows let me go ahead
and open up an example called ASCII 0
recall that ASCII is the mapping between
letters and numbers in a computer and
notice what this program is gonna do
make let me go into this folder make
ASCII 0 dot slash ASCII 0 enter the
string shall be let's say zamyla enter
well it turns out that if you actually
look up the ASCII codes for zamyla's
name Z is 90 lowercase a is 97 M is 109
and so forth there are those characters
and actually we can play the same game
we did last week if I do this again on
like hi
there's your 72 and there's your 73
where is this coming from well now that
I know how to
manipulate individual strings notice
what I can do I can get a string from
the user just as we always have
I can iterate over the length of that
string albeit inefficiently using
sterling here and then notice this new
feature today I can now convert one data
type to another because a char a
character is just 8 bits but presented
in the context of characters bytes is
also just 8 bits that you could treat as
an integer a number right it's totally
context-sensitive if you use Photoshop
at the geographic you use a text program
it's a message and so forth so you can
encode change the context so notice here
s bracket I is of course the Ice
character of zamyla's name so Z or a or
m or whatever but I can convert that Ice
character to an integer doing what's
called casting you can literally in
parentheses specify the data type you
want to convert one data type to and
then store it in exactly that data type
so s bracket I convert it to a number
then store it in an actual number
variable so I can print out its value so
see this is show me the character show
me the letter as by plugging in the
character and then the letter the sorry
the character and the number that I've
just converted it to and you don't
actually even have to be explicit this
is called explicit casting technically
we can do this implicitly to see and the
computer knows that numbers are
characters and characters are number you
don't have to be so pedantic and even do
the explicit casting in parentheses you
can just do it implicitly with datatypes
and honestly at this point I don't even
need the variable I can get rid of this
and down here I can literally just print
the same thing twice
but tell printf to print the first is in
the context of a character and the
second in the context of an int just
treating the exact same bits differently
that's implicit casting and it just
demonstrates what we did in week zero
when we claimed that letters are numbers
and numbers can also be colors and
colors can be images and so forth so
this question also yes that all comes
back to credit well yes indeed other
questions now all right so what else can
we actually do with this appreciation so
super simple feature that all of us
surely take for granted if we even
use it anymore these days Google Docs
Microsoft Word and such can like
automatically capitalize words for you
these days even your phone can do it
nowadays just sort of autocorrect your
messages well how is that actually
working well once you know that a string
is just a bunch of characters back to
back to back and you know that these
characters have numbers representing
them and like capital a is 65 and
lowercase a is 97 apparently and so
forth like we can leverage these
patterns if I go ahead and open up this
other example here called capitalize
zero notice what this program is gonna
do for me first by running it make
capitalize zero dot slash capitalize
zero let me go ahead and type in
zamyla's name just as before but now
it's all capital so this is a little
extreme hopefully your phone is not
capitalizing every letter but you can
imagine it capitalizing just the first
if you wanted it so how does this work
well let me go ahead and open up this
example here and so what we did so here
I'm getting a string from the user just
as we always do then I'm saying after
just to kind of form at the output
nicely here I'm doing a loop pretty
efficiently from I equals zero up to the
length of the string and now notice this
neat application of logic it's a little
cryptic certainly at first glance but
whoops and now it's gone and what am i
doing exactly with these lines of code
well with every iteration of this loop
I'm asking the question is the Ice
character of s so the current character
is it greater than or equal to lowercase
a and is it less than or equal to
lowercase Z put another way how do you
say that more colloquially in English is
it lowercase literally but this is the
more programmatic way of expressing is
it lowercase alright if it is go ahead
and do this now this is a little funky
but print out a character specifically
the ithe character but subtract from
that lowercase letter whatever the
difference is between a little a and big
a now where did that come from so it
turns out Ocasek capital a is 65
lowercase a is 97 so the difference
between those is 32 and that's true for
B so capital B is 66 and lowercase B is
98 still 32 and it repeats for the whole
alphabet so I could just do this
if I know that lowercase letters have
bigger numbers like 97 98 and I know
that lowercase numbers have lower
letters like 65 66 I can just literally
subtract off 32 from my lowercase
letters as you point out it's a
lowercase letter subtract 32 and that
gives us what result the capitalized
version it uppercases things for us but
honestly this feels a little hackish
that like okay yes I can do the math
correctly but you know what it's better
practice generally to abstract this away
don't get into the weeds of counting how
many characters are away from each other
math is cheap and easy in the computer
let it do the math for you by
subtracting whatever the value of a is
capital a is from the value of lowercase
a what we could just write 32 otherwise
go ahead and just print the character
unchanged so in this case the a my LAN
zamyla's name got uppercase and
everything else the Z got left alone
just by understanding what's going on
with how the met computers represented
but honestly god I don't want to keep
writing code like this like I'm never
gonna get this new to programming
perhaps I'm never gonna get this sort of
sequence of all the cryptic symbols
together and that's okay because we can
actually implement this same program a
little more easily thanks to functions
and abstractions that others have
written for us so in this program turns
out I can simplify the questions I'm
asking by literally calling a function
that says is lower and there's another
one called is upper and there's bunches
of others that just literally are called
is something or other so is lower takes
an argument like the 8th character of s
and it just returns a bool true or false
how is it implemented well honestly if
we looked at the code that someone else
wrote decades ago for is upper odds are
or is lower odds are he or she wrote
code that looks almost like this but we
don't need to worry about that level of
detail we can just use his or her
function but how do we do that turns out
that this function and you would only
know this by having been told or
googling or reading a reference is in a
library called C type dot H and you need
the header file called C type dot H in
order to use it and will almost always
point you to references and
documentation to explain that to you to
upper is another feature right at this
math like my god I get someone uppercase
a letter I don't want to really keep
thinking about how far apart leopard
letters are from lowercase turns out
that in the C type library there's
another function called two upper that
literally does the exact same thing in
the previous program we wrote and so
that too is okay but you know what this
feels a little verbose it would be nice
if I could really tighten this program
up so how does to upper work well it
turns out some of you might be familiar
with cs50 reference online or web-based
app that we have that helps you navigate
available functions in C turns out that
all of the data for that application
comes from an older command line program
that comes in Linux and comes in the
sandbox called man for manual and any
time you type man at the command prompt
and then the name of a function you're
interested in if it exists it will tell
you a little something about it so if I
go a to to upper man to upper I get
slightly cryptic documentation here but
notice two upper and some other
functions convert uppercase or lowercase
that's the summary notice that in the
synopsis the man page so to speak is
telling me what header file I have to
include notice that under synopsis it's
also telling me what the signature or
prototype is of the function in other
words the documentation in man the Linux
programmers manual is very terse so it's
not going to hold your hand in this
black and white format it's just going
to in convey well implicitly you better
put this atop your file and by the way
this is how you use the function takes
an argument called C returns a value of
type int where why is it int let me wave
my hands at that it effectively returns
a character for our purposes today and
if we scroll down
okay description I don't really want to
read all of this but okay here we go if
C is a lowercase letter to upper returns
its uppercase equivalent if an uppercase
representation exists in the current
locale that just means if it's
punctuation it's not gonna do anything
otherwise it returns C and that's kind
of the key detail if I pass it lowercase
a it's gonna give me capital a but if I
pass it capital a what's it gonna give
me also capital a returns the original
character C that's the only detail I
cared about like when in doubt like read
the manual and it might be a little
cryptic and this is why cs50 reference
takes somewhat cryptic documentation and
tries to simplify it into more humor
friendly terms but at the end of the day
these are the authoritative answers and
if I or one of the staff don't know like
we literally pull up the man page or see
a safety reference to answer these kinds
of questions now what's the implication
I don't need any of this
I can literally get rid of the condition
and just let to upper do all of the
legwork and now my program is so much
more compact than the previous versions
were because I've read the documentation
I know what the function does and I can
let you upper upper case something or
just pass it through unchanged so we can
better design because we're writing
fewer lines of code that are just as
clear and so we can now actually tighten
things up any questions on this
particular approach all right so we're
getting very low-level now let's make
these things more useful right because
clearly other people have solved some of
these problems for us as by having these
functions and these the C type library
and the string library what more is
there well recall that every time we run
clang or even run make we're typing
multiple words at the command prompt
you're typing make hello or make Mario a
second word or you're typing clang - oh
hello hello dot see like lots of words
at the prompt well it turns out that all
this time you're using indeed
command-line arguments but in C you can
write programs that also accept words
and numbers when the user runs the
program think back after all when you
ran Mario you did dot slash Mario ENTER
you couldn't type any more words at the
prompt when you did credits you did dot
slash credit enter no more words at the
prompt you used getstring or get long to
get more input but not at the
command-line and it turns out that we
can relatively simply in C but it's a
little cryptic at first glance let me go
ahead and let me go ahead and here pull
up this signature here which looks like
this this is the function that we're all
used to by now for writing a main
function and up until now we've said
void main doesn't take any inputs and
indeed it just runs but it turns out if
you change your existing programs or
future programs not to say void but to
say int Arg C string Arg V it's a little
cryptic at first glance but what's a
recognizable symbol now
yeah there's brackets here so it turns
out that every time you write a program
if you don't just say void you actually
enable this feature by writing in artsy
string Arg V you can actually tell clang
you know what I want this program to
accept one or more words or numbers
after the name of the program so I can
do dot slash hello David or dot slash
hello
zamyla I don't have to wait for the
program to be running to use get string
and just as with the earlier example
where you were able to chart an array
main is defined as taking an array
called
Arg V for historical reasons argument
vector vector means array argument
vector bracket close bracket just means
this is this contains one or more words
it's each of which is a string Arg C is
argument count so this is the variable
that main gets access to that tells it
how many arguments how many strings are
actually in Arg V so how can we use this
in a useful way
well let me go ahead here and open up
the sandbox and let me go ahead and
create a new file called say Arg V zero
Arg V zero dot C again argument vector
just list or array of arguments and let
me go ahead and as usual include cs50.h
include standard io standard IO dot H
and then int main not void but int Arg C
string Arg V are V open bracket close
bracket and even F doesn't come
naturally at first it will eventually
and I'm gonna do this if the number of
arguments passed in equals two then I'm
gonna go ahead and do this printf hello
percent s comma and here in the past
I've typed a variable name and I now
actually have access to a variable go
ahead and do Arg fee bracket one else if
the user does not type apparently two
words let me go ahead and just by
default say hello world as we always
have
now why what is this doing and how is it
doing it well let's quickly run it so a
make whoops make our V zero dot slash
argv zero enter hello world but if I do
hello
our daughter iris Larry the program
would be better named if we called it
hello but zamyla enter
hello zamyla if I change it to David now
I have access to David if I David Malin
no it doesn't support that so what's
going on if you change main in any
program right to take these two
arguments RC an Arg V of type string int
and then an array of strings rxc tells
you how many words were typed at the
prompt so if the human typed two words I
presume the first word is the name of
the program dot slash argv zero the
second word is presumably my name if he
or she is actually providing their name
at the prompt and so I print out org V
bracket 1 not 0 because that's the name
of the program but RV bracket 1 else
down here if the human doesn't provide
just zamyla or just David or just one
word more generally I just print the
default hello world but what's neat
about this now is notice that argh V is
an array of strings what is a string
it's an array of characters and so let's
introduce one last piece of syntax that
gets kind of powerful here let me go
ahead and do this let me go ahead and in
a new file here are V 1 dot C let me go
ahead and paste this in close this let
me go ahead and do this rather than do
this logical checking let me do this for
let's say for int I get 0 I is less than
argh C I plus plus let's go ahead and
one per line print out every word that
the human just typed just to reinforce
that this is indeed what's going on so
aren't V bracket 0 save make our V 0
sorry our V 1 enter and now let's go
ahead and run this program dot slash art
v1 David Malan ok you see all three
words if we change it to zamyla we see
just those two words if we change it to
zamyla chan we see those three words so
we clearly have access to all of the
words in the array but let's take this
one step further rather than just print
out every word in the string let's go
ahead and do this for int J get
zero n equals the string length of the
current argument like this J is less
than n j+ + whoops whoops whoops j plus
plus now let me go ahead and print out
not the full string but let me do whip
suppose let me go ahead and print out
this not a string but a character in
bracket i bracket j like this alright so
what's going on one this outer loop and
let's comment it iterate over strings in
argh v this inner loop iterate over
chars in argh v bracket i so the outer
loop iterates over all of the strings in
argh v and the inner loop using a
different variable starting at 0
iterates over all of the characters in
the eighth argument which itself is a
string so we can call string length on
it and then we do this up until n which
is the length of that string and then we
print out each character so just to be
clear when I run Arg V 1 and correct it
at first glance y ax t it's implicitly
declaring library function Stirling
what's almost always the solution when
you do this wrong yeah so I forgot this
so include string dot H and help 50
would help with that as well let's
recompile with make our beat 1 all right
when I run our V one of say zamyla some
milah Chan what am I gonna see yeah is
that the right intuition I'm gonna see
some other Chan but one character on
each line including the program's name
so in fact let me scroll this up so it's
a little bigger enter ok it's a little
stupid the program but it does confirm
that using a race do I have access not
only to the words but I can kind of have
the second dimension and within each
word I can get at each character within
and we do this again just by using not
just single square brackets but double
and again just break this down into the
first principles what is this first
bracket this is the 8th argument the
eighth string in the array and then if
you take it further with bracket J that
gives you the
character inside of this now who cares
about any of this kind of functionality
well let me scroll back and propose one
application here so recall that CS is
really just problem-solving but for
suppose the problem that you want to
solve is to like actually pass a secret
message in class or send someone a
secret for whatever reason while the
input to that problem is generally
called plaintext a message you want to
send to that other person you ideally
want ciphertext to emerge from it which
is in cipher din scrambled somehow
encrypted information so that anyone in
the room like the teacher can't just
grab the node and read what you're
sending to your secret crush or walk
across the room or in any other context
as well but the problem is that if the
message you want to send say is our old
friend high with an exclamation point
you could encode it in certain contexts
as just 72 73 33 and I daresay most
classes on campus if you wrote on a
piece of paper 72 73 33 passed it
through the room and whatever professor
intercepts it they're not going to know
what you're saying anyway but this is
not a good system this is not a crypto
system why it's not secure what do you
think
yeah anyone has access to this right so
long as you attend like week one or zero
of cs50 or you just have general
familiarity with a ski like this is not
a this is just a code I mean a ski is a
Co a system that maps and letters to
numbers and anyone else who knows this
code obviously knows what your message
is because it's not a unique secret to
you and the recipient so that's probably
not the best idea well you can be a
little more sophisticated and this is
back actually a photograph from the
world war 1 of a message that was sent
from Germany to Mexico that was encoded
in very similar way I wasn't using a ski
the numbers as you can perhaps glean
from the photo are actually much larger
but in this system in a militaristic
context there was a codebook so similar
in spirit to a ski where you have like a
column of numbers and a column of
letters to which they correspond a
codebook more generally has like numbers
and then maybe even letters or whole
words that they correspond to sometimes
thousands of them like literally a
really big book of codes and so long as
only in this context the Germans and the
recipients the Mexicans had access to
that same book only they could encrypt
and decrypt or rather encode and decode
information of course in this very
specific context and you can read more
about this in historical texts this was
intercepted this message seemingly
innocuous though definitely
suspicious-looking with all these
numbers of so therefore not innocuous
it's the the British in this case
actually intercepted it and thanks to a
lot of efforts encrypt analysis the
Bletchley Park style code-breaking
albeit further back were they able to
figure out what those numbers
represented in words and actually decode
the message so and in fact here's a
photograph of some of the words that
were translated from one to the other
but more on that in any online or
textual references turns out in this
poem too there was a similar code rights
a perp oh of Bob being in Boston here
you might recall this one listen my
children and you shall hear of the
midnight ride of Paul Revere on the 18th
of April in 75 hardly a man is now alive
who remembers that famous day and year
he said to his friend if the British
marched by land or sea from the town
tonight hang a lantern aloft in the
belfry arch of the North Church tower as
a sick
noelite one if by land and two if by sea
and I on the opposite shore will be
ready to ride and spread the alarm
though every Middlesex village and farm
for the country folk to be up in two
armed so it turns out some of that is
not actually factually correct but the
one if by land and the two F by C code
were sort of an example of a one-time
code because if the revolutionaries and
the American Revolution kind of decided
secretly among themselves literally that
we will put up one lights at the top of
a church if the British are coming for
buy land and we will instead use two if
the British are instead coming by sea
like that is a code and you could write
it down in a book and thus you have a
code book but of course as soon as
someone figures out that pattern it's
compromised and so code books tend not
to be the most robust mechanisms for
encoding information instead it's better
to use something more algorithmic and
wonderfully in computer science is this
black box do we keep saying the home of
algorithms and in general encryption is
a problem with inputs and outputs but we
just need one more input they input is
twich generally called a key or a secret
and a secret might just be a number so
for instance if I wanted my secret to be
one because we'll keep the example
simple but it could really be any number
and indeed we saw with the photograph a
moment ago the Germans use much larger
than this all they did in the context of
codes suppose that you now want to send
a more private message to someone across
the room in a class that I love you how
do you go about encoding that in a way
that isn't just using ASCII and isn't
just using some simple codebook we'll
let me propose that now that we
understand how strings are represented
right we're about to make love really
really lame and geeky so now that you
know how to express strings
computationally well let's just start
representing I love you in ASCII so I 73
L is 76 obe why oh you that's just ASCII
should not send it this way because
anyone who knows ASCII is gonna sit
gonna know what you're saying but what
if I in cypher this message I performed
an algorithm on it and its simplest
sense an algorithm can just be math
simple arithmetic as we've seen so you
know let me just use my secret key of
one and let me make sure that my my my
crush knows that I am using a secret
value of one so he or she also knows to
expect that value and
where I send my message I'm going to add
one to every letter so 73 becomes 74 76
becomes 77 80 80 77090 8086 now this
could just be sent in the clear but then
I could actually send it as a textual
message so let's convert it back to
ASCII 74 is now J 77 is now M 80 is now
P and you can perhaps see the pattern
this message was I love you and now all
of the letters are off by one I think I
became J L became M Oh became P and so
forth so now the claim would be
cryptographically I'm gonna send this
message across the room and now no one
who has like a codebook is gonna be able
to solve this I can't just steal the
book and decode it because now the key
is like only up here so to speak it's
just the number one that he or she and I
had to agree upon in advance that we
would use for sending our secret
messages so if someone it captures this
message teacher in the room or whoever
how would they even go about decoding
this or decrypting it are there any
techniques available to them I dare say
we can kind of chip away at this love
note what's a guess in check okay we
could try all pot there's still kind of
some spacing so you know honestly we
could do like kind of a crypt analysis
of it's a frequency attack like I can't
think of too many words in English that
have a single letter in them so what
does J probably represent I probably
maybe a but probably I and there's not
too many other options so where we've
attacked one part of the message already
I see a commonality there's two what in
here 2p and I don't necessarily know
that that maps to O but I do know it's
the same character so if I kind of
continue this thoughtful process or this
trial and error and I figure out oh what
if that's an O and then that's an O and
then wait a minute they're passing you
know from one to another maybe this says
I love you like you actually can with
some probability decrypt a message by
doing this kind of analysis on it it's
at least more secure than the codebook
because you're not compromised if the
book itself is stolen and you can change
the key every time so long as you and
the recipient actually agree on
something
but at least we
have this mechanism in place so with
just the understanding of what you can
do with strings can you actually know do
really interesting domain-specific
things to them and in fact back in the
day
Caesar back in militaristic times like
literally used a cipher quite like this
and frankly when you're the first one to
use these ciphers they actually are kind
of secure even if they're relatively
simple but hopefully not just using a
key of 1 maybe 2 or 13 or 25 or
something larger but this is an example
of a substitution cipher or a rotational
cipher we're like everything's kind of
rotating a is becoming bee-bees becoming
si or you can kind of rotate it even
further than that well let's take a look
at one last example here of just one
other final primitive of a feature today
before we then go back high level to
bring everything together it turns out
that printing out error messages is not
the only way to signal that something
has gone wrong there's a new key word a
new use of an old key word in this
example that's actually convention for
signaling errors so this is an example
called exit dot C it apparently wants
the human to do what if you infer from
the code yes Segan well what's the what
doesn't want the human to do implicitly
based on the the printf seer how should
I run this program yeah
yeah so for whatever reason this program
implicitly wants me to provide exactly
two words at the prompt because if I
don't it's gonna yell at me missing
command-line argument and then it's
gonna return one whatever that is
otherwise it's gonna say hello
such-and-such so if I actually run this
program let me go back over here and do
make exit whoops in my directory make
exit okay dot slash exit enter I'm
missing a command-line argument all
right let me put some ayahs name
oh hello zamyla let me put Somalia Chan
no missing command-line argument it just
wants the one so in this case here but
it turns out I'm seeing visually the
error message but it turns out the
computer is also signaling to me what
the so-called exit code is so long story
short we've already seen examples last
week of how you can have a function
return of value and we saw how Aaron
came up on stage and she returned to me
a piece of paper with a string on it but
it turns out that Maine is a little
special
if Maine returns a value like 1 or 0 you
can actually see that albeit in a kind
of a non-obvious way if I run exit and I
run it correctly with zamyla as the name
if I then type echo and dollar sign
question mark of all things enter I will
then see exactly what Maine returned
with which in this case is 0 now let me
try and be uncooperative if I actually
run just dot slash exit with no word I
see missing command-line argument but if
I do the same cryptic command echo
dollar sign question mark I see that
Maine exited with 1 now why is this
useful well as we start to write more
use more complicated programs it's going
to be a convention to exit from Maine by
returning a nonzero value if anything
goes wrong zero happens to mean
everything went well and in fact in all
of the programs we've written thus far
if you don't mention return anything
Maine automatically and autom
automatically for you returns zero and
it has been all this time it's just a
feature so you don't have to bother
typing it yourself but what's nice about
this or what's real about this is if on
your Mac or PC if you've ever gotten
like an annoying error message that says
error negative 29 you know system error
has occurred or something freezes but
you very often see numbers on the screen
maybe like those error codes actually
tend to map to these kinds of values so
when a human is writing software and
something goes wrong and an error
happens they typically return a value
like this and the computer has access to
it and this isn't all that useful for
the human running the program but as
your programs get more complex we'll see
that this is actually quite useful as a
way of signaling that something indeed
went wrong okay that's a lot of syntax
wrapped in some loving context any
questions before we look at one final
domain No all right so it turns out that
we can answer the who cares question in
yet another way - it turns out let me go
ahead and open up an example of our
array again here that arrays can
actually now be used to solve problems
more algorithmically and this is where
life gets more interesting like we were
so incredibly in the weeds today and as
we move forward in the class we're not
going to spend so much time on like
syntax and dollar signs and question
marks and square brackets and the like
like that's not the interesting part the
interesting part is when we now have
these been the fundamental building
blocks like an array with which we can
solve problems so it turns out that an
array you know you can kind of think of
it as a series of lockers a series of
lockers that might look like this inside
of which our value strings or numbers or
chars or whatnot but the lockers is an
apt metaphor because a computer unlike
us humans can only see and do one thing
at a time it can open one locker and
look inside but it can't kind of take a
step back like we humans can and look at
all of the lockers even if all of the
doors are opens it has to be a more
deliberate act than that
so what are the actual implications well
all this time we had that phone book
example in the first week and we were
the efficiency of that algorithm of
finding Mike Smith in this phone book
all assumed what feature of this phone
book that it was ordered alphabetically
and that was a huge plus because then I
could like go to the middle and I could
go to the middle of the middle and so
forth and that was an algorithmic
possibility on our phones if you pull up
your contacts you've got a list of first
names or last names all alphabetically
sorted that is because guess what data
structure or layout your phone probably
uses to store your contacts
it's an array of some sort right it's
just a list and it might be displayed
vertically instead of horizontally as
I've been drawing it today but it's just
values that are back to back to back to
back to back that are actually sorted
but how did they actually get into that
sorted order and how do you actually
find values well let's consider what
this problem is actually like for a
computer as follows let me go ahead here
would have Ahlan tear mine joining us up
here I can throw in a free stress ball
maybe someone from back sorry okay come
on up here come what's your name Aaron
all right so Aaron's gonna come on up
and I'm sorry Oh Erik nice to meet you
all right come on over here so Erik
normally I would ask you to find the
number 23 but seeing is that's a little
easy can you go ahead and just find us
the number 50 behind these doors or
really these yellow lockers eights nope
42 no okay pretty good that's three
three out of sevens how would you get it
so quickly okay so he guessed
is that the best algorithm that Eric
could have used here well I don't know
yes no why why yes he has no other
information so yes like that was the
best you can do but let me give you a
little more information you can stay
here and let me go ahead and reload the
screen here and let me go ahead and pull
up a different set of doors and now
suppose that much like the phone book
and much like the phones are sorted now
these doors are sorted and find us the
number 50 okay all right so good what
you do that time all right so you jump
to the middle of you've jumped to the
middle initially and then to the right
half and then technically so we're
technically off by one right because
like binary search would go into the
middle of the that's okay but very well
done to Eric here let me at least
reinforce this with a stress ball so
thank you very well done so with that
additional information as you know like
Eric was able to do better because the
information was sorted on the screen but
he only had one insight to a locker at a
time because only by revealing what's
inside can you actually see it so this
seems to suggest that once you do have
this additional information in Erikson
sample in your phone example in the
phone book example like you open up
possibilities for much much much more
efficient algorithms but to get there
we've kind of been deferring this whole
time in class how you actually sort
these elements and if you wouldn't mind
and this way we'll hopefully end on a
more energized note here because I know
we've been in the weeds for a while
could we get like eight volunteers okay
so one two three four about five six
seven eight
come on down oh I'm sorry did I go
completely overlooked the front row okay
all right next time next time come on
down oh and Colton you mind meeting them
over there instead all right come on up
what's your name call me David right
over there
Matt David Joo hey David max nice to
meet you James James nice to see you
here I'll get more chairs what's your
new painting David and two more actually
can one of you come down to this end
here what's your name
Andrea nice to see you and your name
picot David nice to see you okay
Colton has a t-shirt for each of you
very harbor desk here and each of these
shirts as you're about to see has a
number on it and that number is I'll go
ahead and put them on if you wouldn't
mind okay thank you so much
so I dare say we've arranged our humans
much like the lockers in an array like
we have humans
back-to-back-to-back-to-back but this is
actually both a blessing and a
constraint because we only have eight
chairs so there's really not much room
here so we're confined to just this
space here and I see we have a four a
five two three one six seven so this is
great like they are unsorted by
definition it's pretty random so that's
great so let's just start off by this
sort yourselves from 1 to 8 please
okay all right well what algorithm was
that look around figure it out okay well
KITT a human ingenuity very well done so
can we worst what was like a thought
going through any of your minds
find the chair find the right chair so
go to the go to location good so like an
index location right arrays have indices
so to speak 0 1 2 all the way up to 7
and even though our shirts are numbered
from 1 to 8 that you can think in terms
of 0 to 7 so that was good anyone else
other thoughts okay absolutely could
have gone from right to left instead of
left to right but at least we all agreed
on this convention too so if that was in
your mind okay so good so we got this
sorted go ahead and reran demise
yourself if you could and what algorithm
was this just random awkwardness okay so
that's fine so it looks pretty random
that'll do let's see if we can now
reduce the process of sorting to
something a little more algorithmic so
that one we can be sure we're correct
and not just kind of get lucky that
everyone kind of figured it out and no
one was left out and to then start to
think about how efficient it is right
because if we've been gaining so much
efficiency for the phonebook for our
context for air coming up like we really
should have been asking the whole time
sure you save time with binary search
and divide and conquer but how much did
it cost you to get to a point where you
can use binary search and divide and
conquer because sorting if it's super
super super expensive and time consuming
maybe it's a net negative and you might
as well just search the whole list
rather than ever sort anything all right
so let's see here uh five six and five I
don't like this why six supposed to come
after five and sorry can we fix this
please all right and then let's see okay
six and one don't really like this can
we yeah can we fix this very nice six
and three okay you really got the short
end of the stick here so six and three
could we fix this and six yeah okay okay
six and seven good all right so that's
pretty good seven and eight nice eight
and four sorry could we
which here all right and then eight and
two okay could we switch here okay and
let me ask us somewhat rhetorical
question okay am I done okay no
obviously not but I did fix some
problems right I fixed some
transpositions numbers being out of
order and in fact I can what's your name
again
Tommy it kind of bubbled through the the
right here if you will but like you were
kind of farther down and now you're over
here and like the smaller numbers kind
of yeah one like my god like he kind of
bubbled his way this way so like things
are percolating in some sense and that's
a good thing and so you know let me try
to fix some remaining problems so one in
five good oh three and five could you
switch five and six okay six and seven
seven and four could you switch okay and
seven and two could you switch and now I
don't have to speak with commie again
because we know you're in the right
place so I actually don't have to do
quite as much work this time which is
kind of nice but am I done
like no obviously not but what's the
pattern now like what's the fundamental
primitive if I just compare pairwise
humans and numbers I can in slightly
improve the situation each time by just
swapping them swapping them and each
time now I'm sorry peak go is in number
Seven's place I don't have to talk to
him anymore because he's now bubbled his
way all the way up to the top so even
though I'm doing the same thing again
and again and looping again and again
isn't always the best thing so long as
you're looping fewer and fewer times I
will eventually stop it would seem
because six is gonna eventually go in
the right place and then five and the
four and so forth so if we can just
finish this algorithm good good good not
good okay six and two not good if you
could swap okay what's your name again
Peyton Peyton is now in the right place
I have even less work now ahead of me so
if we can just continue this process 1 &
3 3 & 5 4 & 5 okay and then 2 & 5 and
then what your name again Matt is now in
the right place even less work we're
almost there 1 in 3 3 & 4 2 & 4 & 2 if
you could swap ok almost done and 1 in 3
3 & 2 if you could swap no yes so this
is interesting it would seem that you
know in the first place I kind of
compared 7 pairs of people and then the
next time I went through I compared how
many pairs of people maximally just
six right cuz we were to leave Comi out
and then we were able to leave Pico out
and then paintin and so the number of
comparisons I was doing was getting
fewer and fewer so that feels pretty
good but you know before we even analyze
that can you just randomize yourselves
again any human algorithm is fine
let's try one other approach because
this feels kind of non-obvious right I
was doing fixing things but I had to
keep fixing things again and again let
me try to take a bigger bite out of the
problem this time by just selecting the
smallest person okay so your name again
is Jew hey number two that's a pretty
small number so I'm gonna remember that
in sort of a mental variable for not
you're too big too big too big too big
Oh
James James is a one that's pretty nice
let me keep checking okay James in my
mental variable is the smallest number I
know I want him at the beginning so if
you wouldn't mind coming with me and I'm
sorry we don't have room for you anymore
if you could just oh you know what could
you all just shuffle down well mmm I
don't know if I like that that's a lot
of work right moving all these values
let's not do that not do that number two
could you mind just going where word
James was okay so I've kind of made the
problem a little worse and heading how
number two is farther away from the goal
but I could have gotten lucky and maybe
she was number seven or eight and so let
me just claim that on average just
evicting the person is gonna kind of be
a wash and average out but now James is
in the right place done now I have a
problem that's of size seven so let me
select the next smallest person four is
the next smallest not eight not five not
set two not three six okay so you're
back in the game all right come on back
and can we evict number four and on this
algorithm if you oh I just iteratively
select the smallest person I'm not
comparing everyone in quite the same way
and swapping them pairwise I'm doing son
of more macroscopic swaps so now I'm
gonna look for the next smallest which
is three if you wouldn't mind popping it
on here economy we have to unfortunately
evict you but that works out to our
favor let me look for the next smallest
which is four okay you're back in come
on down swap with five
okay now I'm looking for five a five
there you are okay so go here okay
looking for six all sixth a little bit
of a shuffle okay and now looking for
seven oh seven if you could go here but
notice I'm not going back and this is
what's important like my steps are
getting shorter and shorter you're
getting shorter and shorter
and now we've actually sorted all of
these humans so two fundamentally
different ways but they're both
comparative in nature because I'm
comparing these characters again and
again and again and swapping them if
they're out of order or I'm at a big
higher level going through and swapping
them again and again and again but how
many steps am i taking each time even
though I was doing fewer and fewer and I
wasn't doubling back the first time I
was doing like n minus 1 comparisons and
then I went back here and in bubble and
the first algorithm I kind of stopped
going as far in the second algorithm I
just didn't go back as far so it was
just kind of a different way of thinking
of the problem but then I did what like
7 comparisons then 6 then 5 then 4 then
3 then 2 then 1 it's getting smaller but
how many comparisons is that total if
I've got like n people and being a
number it's not as bad as factorial we'd
be here all day long it's but it is big
it is big let's go let's round of
applause if we could for our volunteers
you can keep the shirts if you'd like a
souvenir thank you very much let me see
if we can't just kind of quantify that
thank you so much and see how we
actually got to that point if I go ahead
and pull up not our lockers but our
answers here let me propose that what we
just did was essentially two algorithms
one has a name bubble and I was kind of
deliberately kind of shoehorning the
word in there bubble sort is just that
comparative store pair by pair fixing
tiny little mistakes but we needed to do
it again and again and again so those
steps kind of add up but we can express
them as pseudocode so in pseudocode and
you can write this any number of ways I
might just do the following just keep
doing the following until there's no
remaining swaps from I from 0 to n minus
2 which is just n is the total number of
humans n minus 2 is go up from that
person to this person because I want to
compare him or her against the person
next to them so I don't want to
accidentally do this that's why it's N
minus 2 at the end here then I want to
go ahead and if the ice and the ice plus
1 elements are out of order swap them so
that's why I was asking our human
volunteers to exchange places and then
just keep doing that until there's no
one left to swap and by definition
everyone is in order
meanwhile the second algorithm
has a conventional name of selection
sort selection sort is literally just
that where you actually select the
smallest person or number of interest to
you iteratively again and again and the
number keeps getting bigger but you
start ignoring the people who you've
already put into place
so the problem similarly is getting
smaller and smaller just like in bubble
sort it was getting more and more sorted
the pseudocode for selection sort might
look like this for i from 0 to n minus 1
so that's 0 in an array and this is n
minus 1 just keep looking for the
smallest element between those two
chairs and then pull that person out and
then just evict whoever's there swap
them but not necessarily adjacently just
as far away as is necessary and in this
way I keep turning my back on more and
more people because they are then in
place so two different framings of the
problem but it turns out they're
actually both the same number of steps
give or take it turns out they're
roughly the same number of steps even
though it's a different way of thinking
about it because if I think about bubble
sort the first iteration for instance
what just actually will let's consider
selection sort even in selection sort
how many comparisons did I have to do
well once I found my smallest elements I
had to compare them against everyone
else so that's n minus 1 comparisons the
first time so n minus 1 on the board
then I can ignore them because they're
behind me now so now I have how many
comparisons left out of n people and
minus 2 cuz I subtracted 1 then again n
minus 3 then n minus 4 all the way down
to just one person remaining so I'll
express that sort of generally
mathematically like this so n minus 1
plus n minus 2 plus whatever plus 1
final comparison whatever that is it
turns out that if you actually read the
back of the math book or your physics
textbooks where they have those little
cheat sheets as to what these
recurrences are turns out that n minus 1
plus n minus 2 plus n minus 3 and so
forth can be expressed more succinctly
as literally just n times n minus 1/2
and if you don't recall that that's okay
I always look these things up as well
but that's true fact so what is that
equal to well that's like N squared
minus n if you just multiply it out and
then if you divide the two then it's N
squared divided by 2 minus n over 2 so
that's the total number of steps and I
could actually plug this in we could
plug in 8
do the math and get the total number of
comparisons that I was verbally kind of
rattling off so is that a big deal
it feels like it's on the order of N
squared and indeed a computer scientist
when assessing the efficiency of an
algorithm tends not to care too much
about like the precise values all we're
gonna care about is like the biggest
term what's the value in the formula
that you come up with that just
dominates the other term so to speak
that has the biggest effect especially
as n is getting larger and larger now
why is this well let's just do sort of
proof by example if you will if this is
the expression technically but I claim
that it's it's close enough to say on
the order of Big O of N squared so to
speak let's use an example if there's a
million people on stage and not just
eight that math works out to be like a
million squared divided by two steps - a
million divided by two total so what
does that actually work out to be well
that's 500 billion minus five hundred
thousand and what does that work out to
be well that's 499 billion 999 million
five hundred thousand that feels pretty
darn close to like N squared I mean
that's a drop in the bucket to subtract
500 thousand from 500 billion so you
know what it's on the order of N squared
it's not precise but it's in that
general order of magnitude so to speak
and so this symbol this capital o is
literally a symbol used in computer
science and in programming to just kind
of describe with a wave of the hand but
some good intuition and algorithm how
fast or slow your algorithm is and it
turns out there's different ways to
evaluate algorithms with just different
similar formulas N squared happens to be
how much time both bubble sort and
selection sort take if I literally count
up all of the work we were doing on
stage with our volunteers it would be
roughly N squared 8 squared or 64 steps
give or take for all of those humans and
that would be notably off there's a good
amount of rounding error there but if we
had a million volunteers on stage then
the rounding error would be pretty
negligible but we've actually seen some
of these other orders of magnitude so to
speak before for instance when we
counted someone or researched for Mike
Smith one page at a time we call that a
linear algorithm and that was Big O of n
so it's on the order of n steps it's a
thousand maybe it's 999 whatever it's on
the order of and
steps the twosies approach was twice as
fast recall two pages at a time but you
know what that's still linear right like
two pages at a time let me just wait
till next year when my CPU is twice as
fast cuz Intel and companies keep
speeding up computers the algorithm is
fundamentally the same and indeed if you
think back to the picture we drew the
shapes of those curves were indeed the
same that first algorithm finding Mike
one page at a time looked like this
second algorithm finding him looked like
this only the third algorithm to divide
and conquer splitting the phonebook was
a fundamentally different shape and so
even though we didn't use this fancy
phrasing a couple weeks ago these first
two algorithms one page at a time two
pages at a time they're on the order of
n technically yes n versus n divided by
two but we only care about the
dominating factor the the variable and
we can throw away everything in the
denominator and we can throw away
everything that's smaller than the
biggest term which in this case is just
N and I alluded to this two weeks ago
logarithmic well it turns out that
anytime you divide something again and
again and again you're leveraging a
logarithmic type function log base two
technically but order on the order of
log base n is a common one as well the
beautiful algorithms are these literally
one-step or technically constant number
of steps for instance like what's an
algorithm that might be constant time
open phonebook okay one step doesn't
really matter how many pages there are
I'm just gonna open the phone book and
that doesn't vary by number of pages
that might be a constant time algorithm
for instance so those are the lowest you
can go and then there's somewhere even
in-between here that we might aspire to
with certain other algorithms so in fact
let's just see if just a moment let's
just see if we can do this a little more
succinctly let's go ahead and use a
raise in just one final way using merge
sort so it turns out using an array we
can actually do something pretty
powerfully so long as we allow ourselves
a couple of arrays so again when we just
did sorting with bubble sort and
selection sort we had just one array we
had eight chairs per people for our
eight people but if I actually allowed
myself like sixteen chairs or even more
and I allowed these folks to move a bit
more
do even better than that using arrays so
here's some random numbers that will
just do visually without any humans and
they're in an array back to back to back
to back but if I allow myself a second
array I'm gonna be able to shuffle these
things around and not just compare them
because it was those comparisons and all
of my footsteps in front of them that
really started to take a lot of time so
here's my array you know it just like
the phone book that phone book example
got us pretty far in the first week let
me do half of the problem at a time and
then kind of combine my answers so
here's an array four to seven five six
eight three one randomly sorted let me
go ahead and sort just half of this just
like I searched for Mike initially and
just half of the phone book so for two
seventy-five not sorted but you know
what let me this feels like too big of a
problem still let me sort just the left
half of the left half okay now it's a
smaller problem you know what four and
two still out of order let me just
divide this list of two into two tiny
arrays each of size one so here's a mini
array of size one and then another one
of like size seven but they're back to
back so whatever but this array of size
one is it sorted sorry no if this array
has just one element and that element is
four yes that it is sorted by definition
all right so done making some progress
now let me kind of mentally rewind let
me sort the right half of that L of that
array so now I have another array of
size 1 is this array sorted yeah kind of
stupidly we don't really seem to be
doing anything we're just making claims
but yes this is sorted but now this was
the original half and this half is
sorted this half is sorted what if I now
just kind of merge these sorted halves
I've got two lists of size 1 4 and 2 and
now if I have extra storage space if I
had like extra benches I could do this a
little better why don't I go ahead and
merge these two as follows two will go
there four will go there so now I've
taken two sorted lists and made one
bigger more sorted list by just merging
them together leveraging some additional
space now let me mentally rewind how did
I get to four into well I started with
the left half then the left half of the
left half let me now do the right half
of the left half if you will all right
let me divide this again seven lists of
size 1 is it sorted yes trivially
five is it sorted yes seven and five
let's go ahead and merge them together
five is of course going to go here seven
of course is going to go here okay now
where do we go we originally sorted the
left half let's go to sort the right out
right sorry now we have the left half
and the right half of the left half are
sorted let's go ahead and merge these we
have two lists now of size 2 2 4 and 5 7
both of which are sorted if I now merge
2 4 & 5 7 which element should come
first in the new longer list obviously 2
& 4 & 5 & 7 that wasn't much of anything
but ok we're just using a little more
space in our array now what comes next
now let's do the right half again we
started by taking the whole problem
doing the left half the left half of the
left half the left half of the left half
of the left half and now we're going
back in time if you will so let's divide
this into two halves
now the left half into two halves still
six is sorted eight is sorted now I have
to merge them 6 8 what comes next
right half 3 & 1 well left half is
sorted right half is sorted 1 & 3
alright now how do I merge these 6 8 1 3
which element should obviously come
first 1 then 3 then 6 then 8 and then
lastly I have two lists of size 4 let me
give myself a little more space one more
array now let me go ahead and put 1 & 2
& 3 & 4 & 5 & 6 & 7 & 8 what just
happened because it actually happened a
lot faster even though we were doing
this all verbally well notice how many
times that each number change locations
for literally 3 right like 1 2 3 right
it moved from the original array to the
secondary array to the tertiary array to
the the fourth array and that's called
and then it was ultimately in place so
each number had to move 1 2 3 spots
and then how many numbers are there well
they were already in the original array
so how many times they have to move just
1 2 3
so how many total numbers are there just
to be clear there's a so 8 times 3 so
let's generalize this if there's n
numbers and each time we moved the
lumbers we did like half of them than
half than half well how many times can
you divide 8 by 2 8 goes to 4 4 goes to
2 2 goes to 1 and that's why we bottomed
out at one element lists of size 1 so it
turns out whenever you divide something
by half by half by half what is that
function or formula it's not power
that's bad that's the other direction
it's a logarithm so again logarithm is
just a mathematical description for any
function that you keep dividing
something again and again and again in
1/2 and 1/2 and 1/2 in 3rd and 3rd and
3rd whatever it is it just means
division by the same proportional amount
again and again and again and so if we
move the numbers three times or more
generally log of n times which again
just means you divided end things again
and again and again you just call that
log N and there's n numbers so n numbers
move to log n times the total arithmetic
here in question is one of those other
values on our little cheat sheet which
looked like this and our other cheat
sheet recall that we had formulas that
looked like this not just n squared and
N and log N and 1 we have this one in
the middle n times log n so again we're
kind of jumping around here but again
each number moved log in places there's
n total numbers so n Times log n is just
by definition and log n but why is this
sorted this way well log in recall from
week 0 with the phone book example the
green curve is definitely smaller than n
n was the straight lines log n was the
green curved one so this indeed belongs
in between because this is n times n
this is n this is n times something
smaller than n so what's the actual
implication well if we were to run these
algorithms side by side and actually
compare them with something like this
let me go ahead and compare these
algorithms using this demo here if I go
ahead and hit play we'll see that the
bars in this chart are actually
horizontal and the small bars represent
small numbers large bars represent long
numbers and then each of these is going
to run a different algorithms select
sword on the Left bubblesort in the
middle mergesort as will now call it on
the right and here's how long each of
them take to sort those values done
bubbles still going selections still
going and so that's the appreciable
difference albeit with a small tunnel
between N squared and something like log
N and so what have we done here we
really really really got into the weeds
of what arrays can actually do for us
and what the relationships are with
strings because all of it kind of
reduces just things being back to back
to back to back but now that we kind of
come back and we'll continue along this
trajectory next time to be able to talk
in a much higher level about what's
actually going on and we can now take
this even further by applying other
certain forms of media to these same
kinds of questions and we'll conclude
it's about 60 seconds long these bars
are vertical instead of horizontal and
what you'll see here is a visualization
of various sorting algorithms among them
selection sort bubble sort and merge
sort and the whole assortment of others
each of which has even a different sound
to it because of the speed and at the in
the pattern by which it actually
operates so let's take a quick look
bubbling up to the top disa T or the the
cycle that it's going in less and less
and less and less work to do
until almost
this is selection sort now so it starts
off random but we keep selecting the
smallest human or in this case the
shortest bar and you'll see here the
bars correlate with frequency clearly so
it's getting higher and higher and
taller and taller
this is mergesort now which recall does
things in halves and then halves of
halves and then merges those halves so
we just did all the left work almost all
the right work that was very gratifying
this is something called gnome sort
which is improving things not quite
perfectly but it's always making forward
progress and then kind of doubling back
and cleaning things up that was a lot
let's call it a day I'll stick around
for one-on-one questions we'll see you
next time
[Applause]